[Music]
buenos dias John s miércoles Trece de
Junio yo soy triste porque yo misplaced
la firewire cable yo tengo record there
el video
lucien de la macbook iSight camera how
do you see [ __ ] in Spanish gotta anyway
I had a bunch of stuff that I was gonna
include in this video but I can't
because it's on the camera and no matter
how much I rub the videotape on the
MacBook the video tape won't get inside
the MacBook it is pretty annoying and I
am a little bit angry spin a very
interesting day and the last part was
not so much fun but the beginning part
was you may notice that it is a
Wednesday and thus I have a song now
this may not be as cool as it would have
been if I had had my footage but it is
still song and it's very short so you
won't have to sit through much of it
anyways it's about my family my family
is getting crazy
27th day
with two more on way démocratie mom and
dad
my getting John Sarah my baby Papa tell
me Sanders Charles Walker Rachel trust
only Braxton Mary kitchen Taylor in
Catherine
Elizabeth grace Catherine me that's just
on my mom's side I hope that some of you
enjoyed that and in my car so I got to
use GarageBand for the first time to
actually make the music which was
interesting to do I don't know that I'm
very good at it yet I might be getting
better especially because for next
Wednesday I have a very exciting at
least to me project that will utilize
GarageBand heavily what John and I did
the day was extremely cool now it's been
a little bit disturbing to be in the
Dominican Republic just laying on the
beach drinking pina coladas when we know
they're not very far away there are a
lot of people in some very bad
situations and my dad was actually able
to get us an opportunity to visit some
of the people in those situations and it
was really really awesome it's just
awesome to see what the Dominican
Republic is actually like here in the
hotel where my family is staying it's
just completely isolated from it just as
isolated as the United States is so we
were very lucky to be invited into this
village and you were gonna get to see
some of that just not today we learned a
very interesting thing from a very
interesting man today and that is that
the people of Haiti are flooding across
the border into the Dominican Republic
because their situation is so much worse
than the people here at the same time
the people of the Dominican Republic are
flooding across the border into Puerto
Rico because the situation in Puerto
Rico is so much better than the
situation in the Dominican Republic and
then the people of Puerto Rico are
flooding into the United States of
America because the situation in the
United States is so much better than the
situation in Puerto Rico and the people
of the United States have been saying a
lot of really nice things about the
Netherlands lately Tobias
here we come let's go find John John yes
I can see you right now